in today's morning Browns a
first-of-its-kind surgical procedure
that could delay menopause by up to 20
years doctors at Pro femme in Birmingham
England have performed it on ten British
women ranging in age from 22 to 36 in
the surgery a portion of a patient's
ovaries are removed the tissue is then
cryogenically frozen when the woman gets
closer to the age of menopause doctors
thaw and replant the tissue that
restores the patient's younger natural
hormones CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus joins us from Los Angeles
good morning dr. agus morning tarika so
I don't know if I personally would want
to delay this because I from what I
understand it's not fun but there are
some real medical benefits in delaying
this can you explain those yeah it's
really you know a remarkable discussion
a hundred years ago the average life
expectancy was in the 50s so now really
we're living or women are living with
four or five decades of having menopause
and so menopause osteoporosis include
heart disease obviously hot flashes
potentially memory problems and others
you can delay that with this procedure
and so this is certainly new this is
experimental but I think it brings out
an important discussion that we should
be having but David it also seems like
there's a reason that nature has
menopause at a certain age so what are
the drawbacks here you're right I mean
the problem is we just don't know I mean
this is an experiment that we're not
going to know the answer to for several
decades
so menopause is part of us right both in
men and women hormones go down in women
much more abruptly in the late 40s and
50s and so for all we know it could
change cancer risk it could change
cognitive function later as you get
older we just don't know the answer and
so my hope is they're gonna follow the
people who go through this and learn
from it we've been doing this in the
cancer space for decades women who are
about to undergo chemotherapy that can
bring on menopause at a very young age
we've been able to store pieces of their
ovary and then reimplantation this is
very different though these are
who don't have in any other medical
issues to delay menopause so David who
should consider having this surgery
obviously not you and I you know I spoke
yesterday with someone at the clinic and
what they told me was is that the
majority of women then of the ten women
who've done it their mothers had gone
through significant side-effects when
going through menopause and so there's
no answer who should have this I mean
presumably someone who says listen
nature says my hormones go down I will
do that or I want to take a pill a day
that actually replace hormones but
here's a biologic way to potentially
keep metal pause delayed you know that
this tissue turns active again as soon
as you put it in and they put it in the
armpit because there's blood supply
there and the power is if you don't like
what's happening they could potentially
take it back out Wow Wow this is
fascinating dr. David agus thanks so
much for being with us this morning
David